last week lawmakers in Georgia passed a
bill that tries to ban all abortions
after a fetal heartbeat can be detected
that's about six weeks into pregnancy
seem like a compassionate thing to do
not everyone agreed though in response
actress and progressive activist Alyssa
Milano says women should fight back in
the bedroom
last Friday Milano tweeted this quote
our reproductive rights are being erased
until women have legal control over our
own bodies we just cannot risk pregnancy
join me and not having sex until we get
our bodily autonomy back I'm calling for
a hashtag sex strike pass it on author
and columnist mark Stein joins us
tonight so mark message you can't have
sex with Alyssa Milano
until we get our partial-birth abortion
back what effect is this going to have
on America
yeah well it's weird to me because the
rationale for abortion such as it is is
that abstinence education doesn't work
so we have to have abortion because
abstinence doesn't work but abstinence
apparently does work when Alyssa Milano
is kabardian
and you just read out the tweet it's
actually fantastically worded we just
cannot risk pregnancy join me by not
having sex so on the on the day that
Doris Day dies we are basically back to
the sexual morality of Doris Day young
at heart circa 1954 in which Hollywood
actresses now are promoting Chase 'less
because the risks of pregnancy from
having sex are too high
woke nurse eventually brings you back to
the same dank slumbers of 60 years ago
it's amazing I find so interesting is if
you were to do a study of the unhappiest
people in America and then isolate the
people with the most influence over our
social policy it would be it the Union
set would be a hundred percent as like
the mo the more unhappy you are the more
influential you are over how people live
their personal lives why is that how do
we get here well I think that's what's
very interesting a lot a lot of these
so-called activists and this is a very
weird reaction to a piece of
policy it's certainly a lot more
draconian than just trying to win a few
local elections in Georgia but as you
say the the happiest people according to
all the surveys of all the uptight
Republicans squares getting boring old
marital sex all over the country now
they were they're a tricky little pajama
boys who agree with Alyssa Milano on
everything and she still won't let him
get to second base it's a tragedy
like why is it I mean it's sort of
unspoken in all this is the idea that
having kids is literally the worst thing
that could happen to you yeah it's like
the end of your whatever your stupid
career is or the things that you think
are so important in your life which by
the way I mean literally nothing in the
end
right right but like where do I get to a
place where a whole political party
believes having children is like a
punishment well what's interesting is
that this was first mooted by
Aristophanes in the Lysistrata - and our
thousand years ago and the idea now that
two-and-a-half thousand years on sex is
just some sort of transactional thing
for women so Bette Midler for example
has joined Alyssa Milano's sex strike
today you know I remember that I
mentioned Doris Day I remember the old
Doris Day joke I think was Groucho Marx
Oscar Levant I knew Doris Day before she
was a virgin I never thought we'd live
long enough for the line I knew Bette
Midler before she was a virgin to become
a thing but it is I think they do not
realize just how deeply weird they they
sound it's interview on rather dull
matters of just electing more of their
side to the legislature would solve this
problem but instead of doing that
they're proposing crazy ideas I don't
think they can help by the way I'm in
favor of more chaste nurse
I think if actresses are going to become
chaste as opposed to twerking all over
the screen then I'm for chaste actresses
rather than twerking actresses
especially if the argument is were so
mad we're gonna stop reproducing okay
yeah it's so pretty
Java boys pity the pajama boys high
tragedy marks done great to see you as
always thank you